[Music]
next week's the finale of cold yes will
you be making an appearance at all I'm
sorry to say that no there will not be
an appearance but it is so insane Brice
like you know how each episode I feel
like just ramps up and Graham something
around something you're like well I
can't be create it's great it's crazier
the finale is insane but in the best way
and I think it's gonna be really
satisfying for everyone that's that
stayed with it are you sure you want to
go through with this one of your
co-stars Colton Haynes yes we were with
him recently we had him leave you a
question he did something and I'm scared
so watch this I can't wait hello Leslie
Grossman that's Colton Haynes your best
friend and your arch-nemesis um can you
talk on Facebook live about when we
would play jokes on you saying that you
had sex scenes in every episode with
different cast members just hint on that
a little bit thanks so much Coleman I
appreciate him bringing that up he
thinks he loves to mess with me Bryce
and I don't know why so I had my first
real big girl sex scene on the show
which was horrifying for me and I
couldn't have been more nervous and
freaked out and like how was this gonna
get shot I was essentially fully clothed
during the whole scene so let's be
honest it wasn't too crazy but he knew
how stressed out that makes me first of
all if I look like Holden I'd be like
whoo let's do 15 sexy like I like to
take my shirt off at all times like who
wants to see me naked
so he would say to me cuz you know you
don't see the scripts in advance and
you're already shooting and no one knows
what's gonna happen the next episode and
he would lie to me and say and he's
really good at lying Bryce he's an actor
he's an actor so he would look at me and
be like I need you to know that I saw I
snuck a little bit and advanced episode
that's a pretty hardcore sex scene with
you and he would and it was everybody in
the cast you like this no it's you and
Billy Eichner
started some Chas and this one's gonna
be you until we walk like he just and
and at first I was like oh my god
really what happens is it totaled
underneath because I was like I'd made
it through my first sex scene I'm like
there's more sex ease and I just said
what he really loved putting me on that
emotional roller coaster so thanks a lot
Colton I really appreciate that and I'm
gonna somehow get you back I don't know
how I'm gonna get you back but you
helped me plan it later Bryce yeah thank
you little brainstorm
[Music]
you